niños desprotegidos en el mundo el
porcentaje de menores de edad totalmente
vacunados contra enfermedades
prevenibles cayó en un 5% y se sitúa en
81% Durante los últimos 3 años debido a
los confinamientos por pandemia y la
saturación de los servicios de salud en
su informe estado Mundial de la infancia
unicef concluyó que 67 millones de niños
en el mundo no recibieron una o más
vacunas y que la confianza en las
vacunas infantiles cayó hasta 44 puntos
porcentuales en algunos países durante
la pandemia algo que podría desencadenar
una nueva crisis de salud
estos datos representan a una
preocupante señal de alarma no podemos
permitir que la confianza en la
inmunización sistemática se convierta en
otra víctima de la pandemia si esto
ocurriera la próxima oleada de muertes
podría deberse a un aumento en el número
de niños y niñas con sarampión difteria
u otras enfermedades prevenibles
el informe muestra que de 55 países
analizados sólo tres China India y
México mantuvieron o aumentaron su
percepción de importancia de las vacunas
antes la OMS había alertado de un
retroceso de la inmunización infantil a
causa de la pandemia según la ONU en
2019 al menos 19,1 millones de niños no
recibieron las vacunas que les
correspondían en 2020 la cifra aumentó a
22,9 millones y en 2021 a 25 millones el
informe también advierte que entre los
factores que amenazan la confianza en
las vacunas está la incertidumbre sobre
la respuesta a la pandemia la
desinformación y la polarización
política